so you grew up you were born in Iraq and
grew up in a right yes I guess what
could now be referred to as the good old
days under Saddam Hussein you think of
them as the good old days because no
right now
I mean I mean it's actually I mean I
started to use the words like it's a
[ __ ] is it okay yeah I mean I
mean living under I mean living under
Saddam Hussein was was not really great
I mean plus I was living under the
sanctions when Saddam Hussein was the
president so these two things those are
twos everything yeah the regime itself
yeah the regime any Hassan sanction lie
by the US and UK and everybody yeah and
I mean it it's a literally a prison
living under Saddam Hussein so what was
it like on any given day you're 13 years
old what was it like well I mean you see
his pictures everywhere and you have to
like when you go to classroom elementary
school you have to stand up and say long
live Saddam Hussein when 9/11 happened
he declared a holiday in the schools in
which this my school was like praising
the Mujahideen oh did 9/11 because he
started like the faith campaign after
the Gulf War that's what there's a lot
of confusion which they they considered
ammo saying to be a secularist his
secular as compared to Isis but that
doesn't say much like a plate probably
al-qaeda's secular compared to Isis
right so but was he really was he just
using religion or was did you think he
actually believed I mean it's I don't I
mean I'm not really good in
psychoanalysis but I think that
regardless of whether he was using it
for his own benefit is like Iraq is is a
sorry a religious Society so using
religion is definitely beneficial to all
of the people it cannot use religion in
Sweden for example but you are
definitely able to use a plus he built a
lot of mosques and and he was all I mean
I mean since the the Gulf War I mean he
started waging jihad against the West
and he starts bringing people like Abu
Musab al-zarqawi Oh became the leader of
al-qaeda in Mesopotamia
he came to Iraq in two like before the
war and so yeah I mean so for your life
though so you're 13 years old yeah and
and what happened yeah when were you
having your sort of your secular
awakening in yourself well I mean the
lucky part of me is that I was raised in
a sort of sort of liberal family I call
them cafeteria Muslims so my my dad was
like said like oh you can think for
yourself and I was like I was reading
the Bible the Old Testament the Torah
the Talmud and all of these stuff and
all of the copy of the Talmud in well
the Internet is even though it was like
the internet but there are some parts
that you can actually get online and
I've seen that all of these religions
make objective claims that of them being
true right so I said okay well either
one of them is true or all of them are
false and I moved like I started reading
more about science and I just realized
that's probably like all of them are
false and but my I would say like my
spark to activism came in after the war
I mean when the first elections happened
in Iraq in 2005 and I was afraid of that
the Shia when they're going to take up
the power the Islamist she I was going
to take the power they're gonna start
discriminate against the Sunnis and that
would lead to a civil war and that
exactly what happened I mean it's very
sad to be right on this subject to
actually saw that coming you felt that
yeah I mean it was very obvious I mean
the moment that Saddam Hussein fall down
the moment is when the Shia start
getting more like they start getting
more mobilized and you can see pictures
of Ayatollah Sistani and most of the
solder and all of these little just
figures and it's very obvious is these
guys are sectarian and so I was started
like well secularism is the virtually
the solution is that try to make Sunnis
and Shias a quote under the law and we
seen we seen that success happening when
when the first Prime Minister I had
allowi who was a secularist when he was
a prime minister there were much less
sectarian warfare happening but the
moment where the Iraqi election happened
is when Islamic party Shia party won and
and that which is my biggest agreement
for the United States when it comes to
us management of the war because I
always thought that the Iraq was not
qualified yet for a democracy and there
needs to be some sort of transitional
period between building a secular
secular civil society and that will take
some time and then you created election
not like after 40 years of dictatorship
you would just make people who many of
them are illiterate would just go for
vote for the best interests of Iraq
right so and we've seen many instances
of this as in Hamas was democratically
elected yeah yeah I'm right using all
the example of a Democrat ejection is
another example of the majority of
people because voted for a Muslim
Brotherhood is that I mean one of the
things of living in their dictatorship
what I would have liked noticed is that
dictatorship skill everybody would
disagree with them so people who are
left out are the ones who don't care
about life so who don't care about life
the jihadist yeah so dictatorships for a
large extent creates ecstatic on Muslims
because they kill all the moderates and
they then give the people a false binary
system is that either you want us or you
want the terrorists and the same thing
happening now in Syria so like with
Assad his and now with the Russian
intervention most of what they're
killing are the moderate rebels who are
in the middle so when when they destroy
the moderate rebels they're going to
give the world two choices you want us
out Isis and I can assure you most
people including myself who chooses
harder for Isis right and and and that
is exists so dick tater ships create
extremism so what happens is that when
this dictatorship go away they literally
created like a hostage crisis they
created like a prison and you get out of
the president eventually you would have
continuous sectarian warfare and
continuous like bad politics and America
was obviously not very well versed in
right and so object' internship there
were lot of focus on like let's get rid
of Saddam Hussein but there was very
little thinking of what after which is
boss dictatorship is much more important
than just getting rid of the dictator
right so where do you place or how much
do you place the blame on the United
States and I guess at that time it was a
coalition that at least
when yeah of course it was mostly us
because I think most people in America
now there's a real sense that it was the
wrong war to go to and they lied us into
the war and all that stuff which I
thought with but the sense of getting
from you is that there was a ton of
really bad stuff going on there anyway
and a lot of it maybe would have bubbled
up yeah I mean there are so many things
that were like I mean Islamic extremism
is done knew it didn't it didn't start
with that with the United States and
didn't start with the CIA or the Israel
or the Mossad so these things have been
I mean have been going on for hundreds
of years in this initial conflict I mean
it started in Iraq and I mean back the
times I think it was called Iraq but I
mean not Jeff and Karbala is where Imam
Hussain Imam Ali were killed and that's
what the split between the Sunni Shia I
think happened and then fast forward to
the modern history Godman Empire who was
at war with the purchase of Owen or the
Persian Empire who are the Shia and
Ottomans were the Sunnis so the conflict
has been going on for hundreds of years
and all these dictatorships are
unsustainable like Saddam was
unsustainable and America did not
intervene in Syria until now recently
after after the Messiah came back is
that that if still they still had the
civil war between Sunnis and Shias and
they still had Isis and al-qaeda and all
of these stuff so it's it's true I mean
I I never thought that and I never think
that the United States is the root of
all problems obviously but I think
sometimes that the United States if some
policies need to be applied based upon
the understanding of the region that can
prevent or reduce amount of sectarian
violence and that my opinion was to keep
some sort of transitional secular regime
that can build a civil society that can
reduce I mean obviously it's not going
to eliminate secular so basically so
basically if you had had a time machine
you would have gone back to right around
the elections when they finally had the
free elections yeah and then you would
have just sort of either so you would
have wanted either American troops or
something there to state just to
stabilize it a little bit longer and yet
at the same time as an American even
though I know it's all gotten worse in
these last three years since y'all out
know we didn't want to
stay there either and that's that yeah I
mean a blade sword the thing I always go
like conversation with like
neoconservatives and things of that of
people who believe like continuous
across a foreign policy is that is it
doesn't fit in with the American
political system it's like an American
system you have elections every four
years and like nation-building you're
talking about the Middle East which is
which we haven't done in four years it
does obviously doesn't get then probably
40 years so so it is unsustainable to
have like a political system in which
like the president has to change every
four years and nation-building
especially in a region that is very
different let's say like Germany during
World War two after World War Two and
Japan is that I mean Iraq is literally
in has the worst neighborhood ever you
have you have Saudi Arabia which is the
which is the rule of the Wahhabi regime
that's not that different from Isis and
you have Iran on the east that is the
the motherlode of Shia Islam and Barak
is in the middle between Shia between
America was expecting like so it come to
Iraq and there's a crazy liberal
democracy in the middle of all regimes
that are theocratic that don't believe
in liberal democracy and and one of them
is an ally which is kind of ironic it's
like so they tried like now with the
city tried to work with non democratic
countries right to create democracy I
mean it makes no it makes no sense
instead to is like the idea that Saudi
Arabia or Qatar or even Iran would allow
a liberal democracy to flourish in Syria
and Iraq is pure delusion yeah they're
not that thrilled with the one liberal
democracy that's in the neighborhood
right yeah I mean well let's hope it
stays I mean it seems it seems like
Israel is going I mean as I can see is
that there is a lot of elements of
theocratic leadership's is now rising up
in Israel which is which make which I
don't think I don't see Israel
contaminate all is going to continue to
be liberal democracy but I see there are
a lot of elements that may not be in the
future
you
you